the cyberlink way were destroyed fool is
not coal mines they see well enough when
Burt here we go nice smoke away some the
scramble has already begun okay stop it
oh come on Steve he's never going to the
Isle of his air breaker animation I love
that movie Oh can't duck bad yeah Steve
that's what we call in the business and
overhead Thank You Tyler mm-hmm see how
you bought yours oh no blocking know a
lot of people I thought their Twitter
really want to see smoke a little more
because I stopped it at ESL you overly
shown yeah to his full potential maybe I
doubt he will be today
all right let's get rid of like this
he's got combos he's good oh yeah almost
have combos Oh Steve do you know the
fatalities I do I got it first try
alright any questions coming yeah that's
true you could easily win this did you
did you get a lot of flak on Twitter for
your ear fate has raha yeah I was not
pleasant do you have a long meeting with
the top brass absolutely job yeah it was
touch-and-go fine hand it back yeah
didn't I say that we hired you because
you can you do fatality yeah you did you
know you're a fatality guy if it hurt my
reputation on this please get it back
maybe we'll see I got one chance here
curious you know obviously the other
that's true you showed three times yeah
oh no I missed it oh man a tippy fair
Leatherface does have a really really
awesome victory silver okay well we'll
probably gonna see it here the second oh
and I smoke away I was confusing thanks
i confuse myself yeah Olli was oh my
gosh oh yeah here's the nasty come back
I think you can do it Oh everyone quiet
here we go all right two out of three
though right Yeah Yeah right that's
that's the tournament standard I was
just a little nervous that time
you